car pour les inconnus parce qu'on va
tous de faire lequel des trois d'accord
alors lequel des trois jeux vous avez
chacun vos pancartes des pancartes avec
vos nom dessus d'ailleurs avec vos têtes
dessus à 1 voilà n'hésitez pas donc
voilà vous avez chacun 3 pancartes ne
les prenez pas pour monsieur moussa nous
a coûté une tonne c'est walry donc
attention vous avez donc les trois
points carte à chaque fois je vous pose
des questions on guide pour vous lequel
lequel des trois frères voulait le mois
à venir chez nous ce soir c'est didier
borloo a quitté bordeaux d'accord très
bien merci les gars lequel des trois
frères et le plus dragueur je séchais la
réponse mais les vrais c'est pour donc
je serais assez bas il l'entendait pas
de messie c'est toujours vous bon droit
avant de prendre la pouvoir le caire
lequel des trois frères pour le plus
gros cachet pour jouer dans un film dans
lequel c'est assez bourdon aussi à
l'envers lequel des trois frères et le
plus drôle pour vous lequel des trois
stères a fait l'amour le plus récemment
et vous bernard vous n'avez pas les
seuls lequel des trois frères danse le
mieux aux maladies
c'est vrai que ça va c'est l'atavisme
série dit mais tu passes calmez vous les
titres dance with me dire oh là et
danses de quoi
pascal c'est vous qui choisissez la
musique
il avait les yeux vous voulez quoi je
sais pas mais il avait les yeux bleus
les cheveux bleus
là bas
je vois quelque chose
m
et dans la baignoire dans la nuit noire
et or pascal et c'est vrai et c'est vrai
qu'ils dansent bien le bougre a pas de
la danse ces machines ont arrêté 55 ans